welcome everyone thank you for joining
us at navigating spatial biology take
that next step with Leica biosystems our
next presentation for today is
implementation of fully automated Bond
RX protocol for nanostrings geomx assay
presented by Carly Hemphill my name is
Marie and I will be your moderator for
today's event before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation
to ask a question click on the Q a box
located on the bottom of your screen
type your questions and hit submit the
speaker will answer your questions
following the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the Q a
box to let us know that you are
experiencing a problem
please join me in welcoming Carly for a
complete biography on our speaker visit
the biography tab on the left Carly over
to you
hello everyone good afternoon my name is
Carly Hemphill and I'm a lead scientist
here at the LabCorp drug development
system uh and I want to thank the
moderators for having me here to present
today I'm going to present on the
implementation of the fully automated
Bond RX protocol for the nanostring
geomix assay and what we've done so far
here to make sure that it is working in
the beta version before the commercial
launch
just for a quick um geomix DSP
technology overview for those unfamiliar
this is a relatively new technology that
combines the ability to have a
pathologist read along with an encounter
or NGS barcoding output and this allows
us to resolve and quantify either
protein or mRNA expression in a
spatially resolved manner so the assay
uses either antibodies or RNA probes and
these are coupled by nanostring to photo
cleavable ogleonucleotide tags and these
tags are combined with up to three
morphology markers plus a nuclear stain
to ffpe mounted tissues
the anglianucleotide tags are then
released from selected regions of
Interest based on the morphological
markers and they are released from the
tissue by UV exposure and collected into
a 96 well plate these tags are then
quantitated in a standard encounter
assay or more recently as we have
implemented by a next-gen sequencing
biolumina and then mapped back to the
tissue location so again this allows us
to have a facially resolved High Plex
digital profile of a certain type of
analyte abundance without doing any type
of degradation to the tissue or loss of
tissue integrity
so the big three points of the
nanostring geomex is the digital spatial
profiling aspect so first the digital as
I mentioned the multi-dimensional
analytes are counted using encounter or
an NGS biolumina the spatial this allows
us to identify regions of Interest based
on either protein RNA scope or
morphological markers and uh this allows
us to have a limited number up to four
fluorescent tagged antibodies or RNA
scope probes that'll help guide the
scientists to a region of interest that
is interesting
and then finally in the profiling the
counts are mapped back to the tissue
location
um on the ROI selecting and so there you
have a yielded a spatially resolved
digital profile
um of the analyte abundance again either
protein or RNA
so this is a typical workflow for the
technology again
um part one is staining either with
those antibodies or with the RNA probes
then we do the secondary stain with the
morphology marker so that again can
either be fluorescently labeled
antibodies or RNA scope fluorescently
labeled probes they are then scanned on
the DSP instrument and the rois are
selected this can be done remotely
if you are vpned or a remote desktop
into the instruments or it can be done
on site and so from there once the rois
are selected we we instrument
initializes the UV cleaving and collects
those into the 96 weld plate and from
there they're either read out on the
encounter for the RNA Plex assays up to
84 or for the higher Plex assays done on
an NGS readout and space and then
brought back into the DSP for that
spatial resolution
so this is the timeline of our adoption
here at LabCorp of the nanostring DMX
profiler so we purchased the instrument
in November of 2019 we had it installed
at our companion Diagnostics lab here in
Raleigh North Carolina
and then from December 2019 to February
2020 we did all of our standardized
instrumentation operational and
performance qualifications and then
training with the nanostring scientists
uh and like a specialist for both the
bond RX protocol the protein i o panel
and the RNA i o panel again this was a
good three months of training to make
sure we were familiar and comfortable
with the system and then beginning in
March of 2020 we started our own
internal projects expanding our
experience there was a presentation done
for the 2020 aacr that shows the
implementation and how it correlates to
different types of outputs in both uh
Multiplex fluorescence and the i o 360
profiling
and as we all know in April 2020
everything in the world changed so our
first collaborations with a lot of our
former partners were put on hold uh as
we were trying to onboard these which
gave us a lot of time to really sit down
with the former partners come in and
make the correct correct make the
corrections to the
uh protocols and definitely study design
so this this time actually gave us a lot
of um
time to reflect on how we can best
design experiments and then it certainly
gave us an opportunity to test the
remote capabilities of the DSP so I
could be sitting safely at home under
quarantine but I could still reach our
nanostring DSP in the lab 20 minutes up
the road and work with Pathologists to
find regions of Interest or design
experiments
and then in May 2021 of this year we
brought on our first custom panel so we
had a client come in working asking for
specific mrnas that were not in the
custom or in the off-the-shelf bio panel
and they also wanted a morphology marker
that had not been validated by
nanostring so this was this has been a
big bulk of our work this year in
addition we have onboarded the Illumina
NGS workflow so that has been a huge
increase we can now run the CTA which is
approximately 1800 genes or the whole
transcript of WTA which is 18 000 genes
we have onboarded that here at LabCorp
and then most recently we brought on
um the Leica team to upgrade our bond RX
with the fully automated protocol that
they had developed with nanostring and
making sure that we can infer our
workflow using going from a
semi-automated staining to a fully
automated run and really reducing the
bench time needed by the scientists
okay so on this slide you can see the
overview of nanostring's current
available panels first on the left upper
left is the protein assays encounter
readout this is the immune immuno IO
core that I mentioned of that we had
done the full training on so this has 18
different protein targets that are read
out by the encounter in addition there
are seven off the shelf add-on modules
that have that range from an additional
5 to 10 antibodies of Interest anything
from apoptosis to map K signaling can be
easily added on as a module and also
this allows for full customization so
any antibody of Interest as long as it
can be labeled by the Olio nucleotide
tag and or a fluorescently labeled for
morphology we can add these into that
protein essay read out
on the upper right hand corner is the
RNA assays encounter readout so this is
the one for those who are looking more
for RNA analyte abundance this the i o
core has 84 immune pathway targets and
you can also add up to 10 additional RNA
probes so these probes are designed in
silicone by nanostring and delivered to
LabCorp as a set that just gets added
onto that I O core and our it is also
read out by the encounter
in the new two newer
um assays that have been developed on
the are on the bottom these are for the
NGS readout which is an Illumina based
sequencing so there's the protein core
and there's up to there's an additional
10 Plex module that can be added on
um so this can do up to 100 protein
targets and get an NGS readout from
those again the modules are flexible and
allows for customization and really
increases the throughput on the amount
of or increases the complexity of the
protein assays that you can run
and then the big the big players over on
the lower right are the RNA RNA assays
for NGS readouts so we have the cancer
transcriptome Atlas which as I mentioned
was 1800 genes and then more recently
the whole transcriptome Atlas which is
available both in human and in Mouse so
either one of those can be used for
these types of studies and that includes
a little over 18 000 genes
so what do the scientist need to do in
the lab based on the current workflow so
it's up to a five-day turnaround time
just for
um for data so when day one is a slide
preparation which is where we do all of
the
um you know the baking epitope retrieval
staining of the probes or antibodies and
then those do an overnight hybridization
on day two is where we do the morphology
staining and then we do the slide
cleanup and we do any type of stringent
washes we'd scan it select rois and then
collect on the DSP
those probes that come off in that 96
well plate are then hybridized with the
uh
um with the encounter or NGS
tags in their hybridized overnight so
minimal Hands-On time there
day three those analyze are collected by
the probes either as I mentioned by
encounter or NGS and put back onto the
DSP so we finally have that spatially
resolved analyte abundance and then day
four is where the data interpretation
really starts where we can look at the
QC of the Run we can do any type of
normalization on the data we can do
background correction any type of
statistical analysis within the software
and then day five is really spent on
data analysis tying up those loose ends
and then report writing and getting the
information back out to the client so
again this is really impressive that
from sample to Multiplex data we can do
this in under a week but we are limited
by the amount of slides that can be put
on the nanostrain Geo mix which is four
at a time so we really have a load
throughput even though it's only a five
day turnaround
and so
this um part right here this slide
cleanup uh and the stringent washes and
the scanning is where the big bottleneck
is and that is because it requires a lot
of Hands-On time for the scientists so
instead of starting a new run or
starting a second set of scans the
scientists is spending up to five to six
hours of uh stringent washes doing the
morphology markings and then getting
those loaded onto the DSP so if we can
fully automate this step we can really
increase workflow
so this is a the previous
um for what I'm going to be referring to
as the semi-automated bond RX assay so
the day one and day two Hands-On time is
where we are losing a lot of critical
space and where we're losing a lot of
our therapy
so on day one obviously we bake slides
and prepare the Leica reagents this
takes up to an hour then there's a three
hour on the bond RX protocol that does
the epitope retrieval and washing we
then offline prepare the hybridization
mix and then manually pipette the probe
mix onto the slides apply apply the
hybridizing uh the hype slip and then
put them into a hybridation
hybridization chamber for 16 to 18 hours
overnight stay two we have to come back
uh take them out of the hybridization
chamber and there's 90 minutes
astringent washing so this really is a
lot of Hands-On quality time that the
scientist is losing doing stringent
washes that could be automated
there's an hour-long incubation of
adding morphology markers on day two in
the morning so that is also lost time
that could have been automated and then
again after that morphology markers are
added the slides are washed and then
loaded onto the DSP which is an
additional 30 minutes so again while it
is semi-automated it is a heavy Hands-On
approach to the assay
and with
operator and run instrument we were
really limited to about to do to
completing four slides a week
then Leica and nanostrain partnered up
and came up with the fully automated RNA
protocol on the bond RX so as you can
see the decrease in day one and day two
Hands-On time is very minimal uh we
still had the big slides and prep
reagents but instead of just waiting for
that three hour run and then doing RNA
probe hybridization and or morphological
markers by hand it is a fully automated
approximately 22 hour run on the bond RX
and then day two these slides come off
it is just a removal of the slides from
the instrument and right onto the DSP so
at that point we can actually prep
reagents for a second run get four more
slides on start that 22 hour run while
we're doing Roi selection day two on the
slides run before so again this really
is a way that we can improve turnaround
time improve throughput and over on the
right you can see that we're not
um this is a picture of a fourplex
um morphology panel and this was
utilized with the automated the fully
automated Bond RX protocol so we're
still getting great
um staining details and we're not losing
any quality in the data because of the
fully automated run
so again in summary we do have an
increase in workflow and turn around or
increase overflow in a turnaround and to
decrease in turnaround time so we have
significantly reduces the Hands-On time
for each slide we have increased
throughput um as many as many slides can
be seen at on the bond RX and in one run
and this increases the throughput on the
DSP as the operator is not tied to the
bench lab work
we recently completed 16 slides in one
week with one operator and one
instrument so as you can tell a full a
four-fold increase in productivity and
ability to turn these assays around
becomes much more beneficial
so while we were very pleased with
how the uh the fully automated assay was
running on the bond RX we wanted to make
sure that we were getting the same
quality data we were doing with manual
run and while uh nanostring came to us
and said we're beta testing rolling this
out would you be interested in
partnering with us and seeing if we are
getting
a same amount of data qualitative
for the specific assays that you guys
are used to running
so we came up with the robust robustness
testing
um experimentation where we were looking
at background signal and does the
background signal intensity change
between the automated and the
semi-automated Run uh is the
housekeeping Concordance
uh similar so are we seeing the same
housekeeping genes at the same frequency
and then finally is a biological
concordance with upheld so does the
interpretal biological outcome differ
between the assays
so here you can see two graphs these are
the negative probes so this is basically
um what your background is going to be
looking like um on the left is the
semi-automated so these are counts for
different negative probe
um across four different
planned
uh with 12 rois per slide and then over
on the right you can see the box plots
with a fully automated run
while um we are seeing less variability
in the fully automated run the more
important part is we're actually seeing
a decrease in overall
amount of negative probes that are
showing up so we're getting a very large
full decrease in the amount of
background probes meaning that the
automated assay is actually giving us
cleaner data than we were getting with
the semi-automated assay and this makes
sense it being a fully automated run the
instrument is much more capable of doing
reproducible
washes of doing more stringent washes of
making sure a five minute wash is
exactly five minutes instead of five
minutes and two seconds making sure the
staining time of the probes is is
exactly at 15 hours where it can be a
little more variable between 16 17 hours
depending on when the scientist was in
the lab and able to return to the
experiment so this was really comforting
knowing that we were getting a decrease
in the amount of negative probes seen
with the fully automated run so this is
actually an increase in the data
analytics as far as we could see
and so here's the data comparison for
the housekeeping genes so um on the
bottom you can see different
housekeeping genes across different scan
IDs so these are the different
um you know scans that we had run this
one we had uh five different
sorry excuse me six different samples
that were run uh comparing the
semi-automated to the fully automated
you can see the housekeeping genes you
know share a similar pattern we're not
seeing
um
and we're seeing the same Trends but
we're also actually seeing an increase
in the housekeeping genes uh raw count
outputs so on the fully automated on the
run we're seeing you know housekeeping
genes registering in the thousands
whereas with the semi-automated Run we
were getting a much much lower signal
intensity so we also found this to be a
plus uh that we are getting much more uh
analyte readout from the same samples
um on known housekeeping genes because
of this fully automated run and I think
the you know the reasoning for this is
exactly the same as we saw with the
background we're just having a more
consistent and more reproducible assay
environment that allows us to really
increase the Integrity of the data so I
think this was
um we're seeing the same Trends we don't
think this is anything that is
biologically insignificant it still
makes sense in the context of the story
it just makes for a better story because
we're getting so many more counts and so
much more
um data above the threshold for the
housekeeping genes so this was really
exciting as well
and then lastly we wanted to look at the
data comparison for the biological
concordance so I just picked a small
subset of the probes that are available
I kind of tried to pick ones that were
known and everyone's familiar with so we
have um you know some of our
CD3 CD4 markers
um ctla for Fox B3 lag three everyone
who's familiar with the i o space is
really interested in in what we were
seeing um as far as the fully automated
versus the semi-automated
so again we can see
um the scale bars are
um are a little
uh skewed on the side just for graphical
reasons to be able to fit them on the
same but if you do look at the scale
bars you can see that we are getting the
increase in counts for the fully
automated run versus the semi-automated
run but we're seeing the same Trends
we're seeing that CD
um at CD 86 is still much higher
um so that biological concordance is
preserved and the pd1 is still higher
than the rest of them so we're seeing
that uh that same biological concordance
but we're seeing it at a much better
scale so we're getting higher counts
higher readouts and therefore better
signal intensity with the fully
automated run so in conclusion we really
appreciated uh the ability of Leica and
Nano string to work together to allow us
to onboard this fully automated protocol
producing
um not only an increase in our ability
to
um get more slides done in a week but
also increase the quality of the data
coming off of our instrument because of
the lack of variability between runs so
thank you so much for your time and I
welcome any questions
thank you Carly for that informative
presentation
quick reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the Q a box and click on the send button
we will answer as many questions as we
have time for
our first question is how can spatial
profiling workflows help in gathering
Multiplex data
thank you for that question
um so the spatial profiling aspect
really helps us get higher dimensional
data so from traditional methods such as
uh well you know IHC or mif we are
limited in the number of markers that we
can explore but um with the spatialized
data we can still get that spatial
context but also certainly get a lot
more data points from the rois
wait next question
are there any similarities between
spatial profiling and more traditional
Multiplex methods
um there's some
some similarities you can see from the
presentation of the multiplex is
staining so that basically Builds on the
traditional methods of more of the more
traditional analysis but
um the ability of the sampling to look
at several different
um
phenotypes and if you look at several
different signaling Pathways gives it an
edge on the current
um
uh the current traditional assays that
are available
so yeah I was just I was going to follow
up with um any differences to consider
differences
um really just the workflow the ability
to get large amounts of Multiplex data
from the analysis compared to Just A
visual representation you can search
different types of analysis Downstream
of Multiplex if but the digital spatial
profiler really allows you to get a more
comprehensive View and larger amounts of
data
great next question
how do the morphological markers help
guide the selection process for rois
uh so the morphological markers are
really helpful
um first you could they're customizable
so any type of Target that you're
looking for as long as you can
fluorescently label that antibody you
can use it as a morphological marker so
this really helps us to get customized
work done and especially if there's a
specific drug Target or a specific cell
type that we're looking for information
around that cell uh it helps us really
hone in and make sure we are getting the
correct rois and getting the answers for
the questions that are biologically
relevant
thank you next question can we use it
from mitochondria function analysis
I personally have not used it for
um any type of mitochondrial function
but certainly the gene list exists and
so I I
don't see any hindrances to why it would
not work
um you can't get down into the you know
single cell phenotyping but um you know
there's a specific Pathways you're
looking for in a you know a general area
that you could uh definitely utilize the
dfp for that type of information
great thank you and it looks like we
have time for one more question what are
the most common areas of research that
your clients are using DSP in your lab
outside and within oncology
so certainly um oncology is our biggest
uh on interest in immuno oncology is
probably 90 percent of that work
um
and so but we're also seeing a increase
in the
um neuro panels that are available so a
lot of interest in Alzheimer's uh any
type of disease aging process those have
started to come in
so that is
um you know the biggest areas that we
see
um
and then so
I think another big part of DSP is the
availability of the customization so we
have a lot of clients that come in and
have a very specific drug Target and we
so if there's an antibody to
um you know that drug Target we can see
if that's localized within the tumor see
if that
um you know was going on in that area
where the drug Target is
um either entering or unable to enter
into the tumor for efficacy
great thank you
um it looks like we do have some time
for another question
um when when is the whole transcriptome
assay being used by your clients
I'm assuming this is a one in not a
timeline sense but a one is in an
experimental sense so we'll answer it
that way
um it is currently already being used so
I guess that's the answer to the
timeline when people are using it and
engaging with it is really for early
Discovery phases so if
um you know there's a specific mechanism
of action study that is a relevance that
those are very popular with the whole
transcripts of Atlas because you can
really go fishing for large amounts of
um and get a lot of amounts of data so I
think that is the real advantage of the
WTA and
um as far as using it for
um like Diagnostics we aren't at that
point yet but a lot of times the clients
will come to us and ask I have a drug
that works um but we're not sure why it
works and we will certainly recommend
the WTA or the whole transcriptome Atlas
at that point because you can really
look at several different signaling
pathways on a whole genome level
well great a big thank you to Carly and
thank you to our audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions we will address any questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during our on-demand period
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this session webcast will be available
on demand after the event
that's all for this session thank you
for joining us and we hope you've
enjoyed the presentation bye for now